I know it's gonna be a lazy home school day when my day starts with a little guy
in my day I need a full 8 hours of sleep to function
and I definitely did not get that last night
so I am dragging today it's often rainy and overcast
which is not helping so we enjoyed a really slow morning with Christmas music
decorating and some outside time
and then we were all ready to jump into our day
we do block schedule so today was math history in bio
I often get asked if I double up on math and reading lessons
I only do it twice a week
and the answer is no because I do not care about getting through my curricule
the goal is mastery so I do a lot of activity that cover the same task
so I'll teach a new concept and model it for them
and then we'll do a gamer activity and practice it together
and then they'll practice it by themselves
and then we also review things we've already covered
so I usually spend about an hour to an hour and a half
teaching that subject each day
this helped my kids master concept so much faster
but I couldn't go that deep if I did reading and math in the same day
so that is why I split them up and do block scheduling